- Today on Drew,
we wrap up our look back at season one.
Our first kiss and it was not onscreen.
- I remember that.
(Drew laughs)
- [Announcer] It all starts Monday.
The Drew Barrymore Show
is on location from LA.
Hollywood's biggest stars
and big hometown surprises.
(Drew yells)
- Oh my God, we have to stop.
It all starts now.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Please
welcome Drew Barrymore.
- Hi, everyone, I can't
believe that season two
of The Drew Barrymore Show
starts this Monday, September 13th.
And we're so excited that we decided
to make it a two week premiere event,
celebrating hometowns and that feeling
that there is no place like home.
And next week, we're kicking
off the season in my hometown
of Los Angeles and then
we're headed back here
to my new hometown of New York.
But we wanna celebrate
your hometown as well.
So write into TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
and tell us why your
hometown is special to you.
Today, we're wrapping up
a week-long celebration
of our favorite moments from season one.
And we have a very special surprise
for an incredible Drew Gooder.
Her name is Alicia White
and she was born and raised in Queens.
And after seeing the neglect
of parks and outdoor spaces
in her area, she created Project Petals,
a nonprofit focused on
revitalization and development
of underserved communities.
Alicia is backstage right
now with her sister, Tiffany.
And guess what?
They think they're here to
get a tour of the studio.
They have no idea we're filming
right now and at the end
of the show, we're gonna surprise them.
Guess what with?
Well, you're gonna have to find out.
Right now, let's dive into
more memorable moments
from last season.
First up is a guest I was
honored to share scenes with.
Oh, Hugh Grant, otherwise known as Hubert,
is someone I just love so much.
And he stopped in and
we covered everything
from our first conversation
to our first kiss
and it was not onscreen.
Uh-huh, watch this.
Let's start on how we first met.
Do you remember?
(Drew laughs)
We actually didn't meet in person.
I reached out to you.
- Oh my God, you did!
You were so nice.
You were so nice, yes.
It was during the dark days
of my Divine Brown scandal.
I was just an idiot.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
I was a grown up idiot who
got caught by the police.
And I was back in England with
5,000 members of the press
around the borders of my farm.
And I opened a letter from you
that was very supportive and nice.
And it was very cheering up.
And I thought I love Drew Barrymore.
Words of support from an actress
I didn't know in Hollywood
was lovely, so you'll always
have a place in my heart.
- Oh, I loved you so much.
That whole incident just
I related in my own life
and I think that whether
it's an actor or a politician
or anything in between, we
expect people to be infallible,
perfect, never flawed.
And God forbid we do anything
in our personal lives
that we would like to remain personal,
but we don't have that
privilege at a certain point
because the cat gets let out of the bag
and I just had to reach out to you.
I just appreciated you and I was so...
I mean, and you were just
the most charming human.
I loved getting to know you
on our movie, "Music and Lyrics".
And it's just one of
my very favorite movies
and it makes me so happy.
It was a good movie, it was a happy movie.
- I agree with you
'cause I love to hate
the films I've been in.
And I do hate some of them.
(audience laughs)
But "Music and Lyrics",
it's impossible to hate.
We're so good in it
and so charming.
(audience laughs)
- If you think I'm good in
it, that means a lot to me
because I have the
deepest respect for you.
Beyond your charm and your heart,
your talent is just unparalleled.
And you've had a long body of work,
so you shan't argue me
out of that hypothesis.
- But it wasn't, but Drew,
I think that film works
maybe we acted quite well,
but here's the weird thing.
We had chemistry and there
were people I remember
before we shot that,
"It's a bit disgusting
"'cause he's 180 and she's like 20."
But actually, we had a bit of chemistry.
- We really did.
And it was funny too
because when Hugh and I met,
Hugh, you can be a bit of a
curmudgeon from time to time
(audience laughs)
and I of course am like a
Labrador in heat and (Drew pants)
I'm so excited with joy.
And so when we both met, we were like,
oh, we're kind of different people.
- That is absolutely true.
- It was.
- Maybe that's why it
had a bit of crackle.
- And then we really
got to know each other
and accept each other for who we were
and it became easy.
And then we just used
to sit around and laugh.
That being said, one of the moments
that I had some of the most moxie,
and I don't think we've
ever talked about this,
I walked into I think it
was like the Waverly Inn
and this was years ago
and I'd had a few drinks.
(Drew laughs)
And I walked in and I ran into you.
And instead of saying hello,
I grabbed you by the collar
and I fully started kissing you.
- Yes.
(audience laughs)
I remember that.
- Can I do you of what I saw?
- Yes, yes, please.
- You went...
- [Hugh] I don't think that's true.
- But you were like, oh.
The expression was you've never
greeted me that way before.
And then you were like
had a second thought
and you were like, you
know I'm not hating this.
And then we flirted and then
it was like we were like,
okay, yeah, bye, see you soon.
- It was really bizarre.
I was very drunk as well.
And I was with some very nice
but not drunk studio executives from LA.
And they were very surprised.
Someone said, "Oh,
there's Drew Barrymore."
I get up to say hi and then
we make out for 10 minutes.
And then I sit down again and
I'm talking about the script.
- Well, I guess we've grown up a bit.
Do you think growing up
is overrated, Hubert?
- Yeah, I hate responsibility.
I don't want this.
I'm looking after five
children and an elderly father
and I don't like it.
I keep looking around
for someone more grown up
to come and do it for me.
It's awful.
- And yet, the last time we
talked, the way that you talk
about the way you look at life now,
having five children's eyes
to look through, look after
and look into, you seem very changed.
- I'm simultaneously utterly
exhausted and miserable
and I'm clearly the
happiest I've ever been.
I see that now.
It's so nice.
All those cliches are true.
All that love is just so nice.
- I think that--
- Not just the children,
but the wife as well.
I have a top wife.
You must meet her, she's terrifying.
(audience laughs)
Swedish, much more
manly than me in terms--
(Drew laughs)
But really cool and now you see I'm happy.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, Hugh, I just...
(Drew swoons)
You're the best.
More memories with Hubert when we return.
Don't go anywhere.
(upbeat music)
I want juice, dirt.
I wanna pull back the curtain
on some of your most iconic roles.
- Rene was a genius at
being British Bridget.
But I do remember that she came in
for the first read through
and she sounded very, very posh.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Welcome back.
All week long, we're bringing you some
of our favorite stand out
moments from season one
with some director's cut
commentary sprinkled in.
And when Hugh Grant came on the show,
he revealed some director's
cut commentary of his own.
We asked him to pull back the curtain
on some of his most famous films
in something we call Behind the Scenes
and he did not hold back.
Take a look.
I wanna pull back the curtain
on some of your most iconic
roles in something we like
to call Behind the Scenes.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
Okay, I want juice, dirt,
fly on the wall, anything
that comes to mind when I
mention these movies if you will,
please and thank you.
Let's start with "Notting Hill".
- [Hugh] There's so much.
- [Drew] Oh, give it to me, Hubert.
- Remember the scene with the brownies
when everyone's sitting
around having dinner
and it's about who's gonna
eat the last brownie?
- Yes.
- Hugh Bonneville who Americans
think is a classy actor,
what he got up to during that scene
deliberately putting brownies on my chair
so that I would sit on
them in my white trousers
and then they could all laugh at my bum
in between takes.
I remember that.
- Okay, "Four Weddings and a Funeral".
- Well, yeah, panic.
I remember the director, he
really, 'cause we had no money,
we made that film for a
minuscule amount of money
and in 36 days.
And he just lost it all the time.
He would throw his cup
of tea against the wall
and say, "(bleeping) I
can't make this film!"
(Drew laughs)
And we said, but you have to,
you've gotta shoot
another whole scene here.
It's two pages and he'd say,
"Oh, but there's five
minutes left in the day."
And so he'd say, "Stand
against that wall."
It was like we'd just
stand there in a line
and we'd just be the line
with one camera on us
and that is there is a
scene in the film like that,
took seven minutes to shoot.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
- Okay, I'm so glad I asked.
Okay, "About a Boy".
- "About a Boy", he's a big star now,
not that baby, but the boy.
(Drew laughs)
- Nicholas Hoult, by
the way, and he's hot.
- [Hugh] Yes, yes and we chose him
because he was such a nerd and a geek.
- I know, I mean, with all due respect,
he's posed as a real outsider boy
and he grew up to be really hot.
- Yes, yes, he did.
- Okay, "Bridget Jones Diary".
- Well, there you have
Rene who was a genius
at being British Bridget, but
I do remember that she went
through some interesting phases on the way
to getting that British
accent during rehearsals.
She came in for the first read through
and she sounded like Princess Margaret,
very, very posh and grand.
And then the next time she came in,
someone had told her obviously
that maybe bring it down a bit.
But then she sounded a bit
like she'd had a stroke.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
And then she absolutely nailed it.
It's an absolute triumph.
And of course, she did
that accent not just
in the performance but between
takes and she never reverted
to American until the wrap party
when that was the first time
I'd ever heard her speak
with her Texan accent
and I quite honestly
found it unconvincing.
(audience laughs)
- I love that detail and
I love hearing that intel
of her process.
Great, thank you so much.
Okay, "Mickey Blue Eyes".
- Oh, well, that's Jimmy Caan
and what can I tell you about?
Well, I can tell you that
with my then-girlfriend,
Elizabeth Hurley produced the film
and we had a lot of let's call
them specialists or advisors
on the set who knew all
about the New York mob.
Let's just say that.
And she was brilliant with them.
If we needed anything done,
she would flirt with one
of these guys and she'd go
and sit on one of their knees
and compare their manicures.
And say, "Oh, no, you've
got such lovely jewelry
"and such lovely nails."
And they'd do anything for us.
We know if we had a problem
with planes going overhead
ruining the soundtrack, one
of them would get on the phone
and suddenly, JFK had
redirected all the planes
from that particular part of Manhattan.
- Oh my God, I love that story.
I'll never forget you and her stepping out
and she was in that
Versace safety pin dress.
You know there are
iconic moments in fashion
and that will always be one,
that evening you two stepped out.
- Well, yeah, it ended up that
way, but it was a pure fluke.
We were unsuccessful actors.
Well, we weren't that unsuccessful
but we were not well known in any way.
And suddenly this big premiere
comes along for this film
and she has nothing to wear.
And I think I said, I
think you can borrow stuff.
I think that's what people do.
The big designers will lend you something.
And so we rang around.
We didn't have an assistant or a publicist
or anything like that.
We plucked up our courage, rang around
and they all said, "No, who are you?"
And then Versace said,
"Yes, we got something
but only one thing."
And they sent it round
and it was this was the
one dress that arrived.
And she put it on
and I remember being
slightly startled by it.
(Hugh laughs)
- [Drew] Oh, I bet you were.
- [Hugh] Hot.
Anyway, and then the rest is history.
It became a thing.
(audience applauds)
- Elizabeth Hurley's safety pin dress,
yeah, that's always going to be iconic.
All right, our season two
pre-party is just getting started
and we will be right back
with more season one
memorable moments in a minute.
Don't move.
(upbeat music)
The internet moves so
fast I can barely keep up.
Luckily, our team combs
through it every day
bringing us jewels like this.
- Hi, Drew.
I'm Autumna California Bailey.
I love skating, watch me!
(light music)
- That was a real gem.
Thanks, internet.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back.
We're checking out some
of our favorite moments
from season one to get geared up
for our big season two premiere
this Monday, September 13th.
Next up is a segment
where I got to eat dessert
while chatting with adorable kids.
It doesn't get much better than that.
Joshua, Isaiah, Caleb and
Micah are better known
as the Yummy Brothers.
They're kid entrepreneurs
who turned their family cookie
recipes into a business.
And we had a surprise for them
and it turned out they had one for us too.
And anyway, watch this.
How did you guys get
into the cookie business?
- First, we went to go ask our mom
would she approve of the business.
Then she told us to go
sit down with our dad.
And our dad eventually he agreed to do it
and we came up with the name and the logo
and it went off from there.
- Joshua, what has it been
like working with your brothers
and starting a business?
- Well, it has been really
fun to be able to work
with brothers, my mom and my dad.
And another thing that I really love is
that we're inspiring kids
and adults across the world
to be entrepreneurs.
(audience applauds)
- I mean, that's so wise.
Micah, you guys are going to school
and running a successful business.
How are you managing it all?
- Well, how we're doing this
is we do our schoolwork first
and then we bake the cookies.
(audience laughs)
- Caleb, what are you gonna do
with the money you're making?
- Well, actually we
created another business
called Kidpreneur Expo
which is an online platform
that allows kidpreneurs that advertise
and market in their business.
(audience applauds)
- That's really smart.
I learned early that marketing
and advertising is very important
because it's how you tell your story.
And it's a great way
for you to take control
but also make sure it's
exactly the way you see it.
Isaiah, you are all such cool dudes.
What would you tell someone
who thought baking was a girl thing?
- Well, Drew, that's an awesome question.
Let's say in my trip of imagination
you're on a Saturday
morning having some coffee,
probably just relaxing and
you have your cookies baking
in the oven at 350 degrees.
Then when they get out, you take a bite
and ooey gooey chocolate
all over your mouth.
- [Isaiah] And another thing, Drew.
- [Drew] Yeah.
One of our biggest supporters
was our grandfather.
And he would always tell us
whatever you put your mind to
you can always do it.
- I am so excited to
be talking to you guys.
And I know that you sent us
some of your yummy cookies.
Okay, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
What do we have?
Walk me through it, gentlemen.
- All right, so we have the two face
which is double dark chocolate
mixed with chocolate chip.
Then we have chocolate
chip, snickerdoodle.
Then there's cookies and cream,
Papa's white chocolate macadamia nut
that was named after our grandfather
because he loved macadamia nuts,
and then oatmeal.
- [Drew] Mm-mm.
(audience laughs)
- Cookies that we picked out for you
is Drew's ET cookie,
which means extra tasty.
- Oh, I love it!
(audience applauds)
Oh, gosh, you gentlemen are
so handsome and so talented.
Oh my gosh.
- [Isaiah] In the Drew's cookie,
there's pecans, toffee and chocolate chip.
- I must tell you guys
these are truly some of the
best cookies I've ever had
in my life and I'm not just saying that.
These are perfect.
Their texture is exactly what you dream of
and there are so many different flavors
from all the different nuts.
They're incredible.
You guys have made an
extraordinary product.
And I know that one of your goals is
to sell your cookies nationwide.
And I actually heard that you
would love to sell in a store
and I reached out to the
owners of Slim and Husky's,
the first black-owned pizza
franchise in the country.
- Awesome!
- We love that place.
We go there all the time.
Their food is great.
- Their successful pizza
empire has stores nationwide.
And I would love to welcome
in the wonderful co-owners
of Slim and Husky's,
Clint, EJ and Derrick.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
- How are y'all doing?
- What's up, fellas?
- Man, it's great to meet you guys.
We wanted to hop on
and say congratulations
on all you guys' success.
You guys are true leaders
for your communities
and your families.
I just wanna tell you to keep on going.
The best is yet to come for you guys.
- Thank you.
- Man, we just want you
guys to know if you focus,
continue doing what you love
with the people that you love,
man, you can't go wrong.
So much success to you guys.
- What we're going to do is allow you guys
to sell your cookies
in our Atlanta stores.
How does that sound?
(audience applauds)
- Let's go!
- Awesome, awesome.
So what we'll do, we'll work together
on a marketing strategy
and we'll figure out
how to make it all work.
That sound good?
- Yeah, great.
- [EJ] Awesome.
- Thank you for having us here.
- We're obviously if we could
be so lucky to have each
and every one of you up on our website.
It's TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
shining lights
on your businesses.
We love all of you
and everything that you're doing
in your business communities,
as well as being really smart businessmen.
- Thank you so much.
But Drew, you know what would be good?
If we did an exclusive Slim
and Husky's special cookie.
(audience applauds)
- We like that.
- [Clint] We love it.
- [Derrick] Let's make it happen.
- How impressive are those boys?
The best, and since we last saw them,
the Yummy Brothers marked
a special milestone.
They welcomed another brother
into the family business.
Baby Andrew is now the
fifth Yummy Brother.
And we hear he's been assigned
to the very important task
of taste-testing the cookies.
We wish them all the very best.
Now, we have to take a quick
break, so I'm gonna go see
if we have any leftover
cookies in our kitchen.
So we'll be right back with
more season one memories
and fun facts.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back to our season two pre-party
and we're checking out some
of our favorite season one moments.
And I'm throwing in a little
behind the scenes commentary,
stuff you wouldn't have seen before.
I am truly obsessed with this next guess.
All season long, I was vision boarding
and trying to manifest that
she would come on the show.
And finally, my dream actually came true.
And her appearance truly sparked joy.
This is our conversation
with the declutter queen, Marie Kondo.
Take a look.
I have a question, Marie,
when I first discovered Marie Kondo,
I was basically a hoarder.
I had 15 layers to everything.
The chair had a pillow
and a throw blanket.
And I wonder when you
do start to take away
and go layer by layer and
get to a more sane place,
a less crazy place,
something that feels
more settled and calm,
what do you do when life and
kids and the natural layers
of things come back in?
- (foreign language)
- With children, it's really easy
to accumulate a lot of items and clutter.
But in those instances,
I work with the children
to talk to them and hey, what sparks joy,
what makes you happy?
And I have them play and
then you integrate them
into the process.
- Oh.
(audience laughs)
Oh yeah, no, I wasn't doing that.
So now I should go with my children
and take them through their things
and figure out what sparks joy for them.
And then we can prioritize
what we should keep
and what we should let go of.
Is that the right advice?
- (foreign language)
- Absolutely, talk about
this with your kids.
And it's very important
that at a young age
they understand what it means to spark joy
and what sparks joy to them.
- You have a new online tidying course.
Will you please tell us about that
so we can all watch it and learn?
- (foreign language)
- Absolutely, so what
this is is a visual guide
to the tidying process.
And of course, if you read the book,
some people can visualize
it, but this really helps
because it is a very visual
medium to see the process,
how it gets done and help people go
through the entire process of tidying up.
- Last week, I was mesmerized
by how you fold underwear.
The underwear you chose were very petite
and I tend to wear something
that looks more like a parachute.
(audience laughs)
Like, if there's a fire, we
should all grab my underwear
and use it.
(audience laughs)
How would you fold a fitted
sheet or my underwear?
(audience laughs)
- [Marie] (foreign language)
- [Interpreter] So you wanna
take the most important bits
and fold it to the top like so, inward.
- [Marie] (foreign language)
- [Interpreter] Oh, you
could fold it in half.
- [Marie] (foreign language)
- Because this is cotton and
it's a very rigid fabric,
you don't have to fold it as many times.
- [Marie] (foreign language)
- [Interpreter] Perfect!
(audience applauds)
- I appreciate you so much.
What you've put into the world,
you've helped and allowed
and normalized us asking what
joy is and how we find it.
I think I'm gonna have to pinch myself.
I just wanna say, Marie, that
I truly hope to make you proud.
I have your picture on my desk
and I hope that I haven't scared you away.
(audience laughs)
- (foreign language)
- I am ecstatic right now.
Let's go spread more joy around the world.
- Yes!
Marie, I love you.
You have changed my life.
I look at everything now
just in a different way
because of you.
And we'll be right back with
more memories from season one.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back.
We're watching some
memorable season one moments
and sharing behind the scene tidbits,
some stuff you didn't see onscreen.
It's a little season two pre-party.
Of all the amazing guests we
welcomed during season one,
this big, tall and handsome guy
was one of my very favorites.
I like to think we really
are birds of a feather.
And he even came dressed
in the show's signature yellow color.
It's the one, the only, my
lifelong love, Big Bird.
He joined us to celebrate
World Kindness Day.
Watch this.
How is your morning so far?
Always early, Bird?
(Big Bird laughs)
- Well, my day is going
great here on Sesame Street.
And you know the old saying,
the early bird gets the bird seed.
(audience laughs)
(Big Bird laughs)
(Drew laughs)
- Yes, it does.
I'm tongue tied 'cause I'm
so excited to be meet you.
- Well, I'm excited to meet you.
- It's a dream come true
and today is World Kindness Day.
Do you mind explaining
what it's all about?
- Oh sure, well, I could tell
you what kindness is about.
Kindness is about showing
people how much you care.
And you can be kind to animals
and the environment too
and it makes my friends feel good
when I'm kind to them.
So that makes me feel good, you know?
- Yes, it's true.
It's funny, the nicer you are to people,
strangely, the better you feel yourself,
but how do you show
kindness to your friends
on Sesame Street?
- Whenever I'm sad, my best
friend, Snuffy, he calls me
and he cheers me up.
And that's really kind.
And also Grover, he always holds the door
when he sees someone
leaving Hooper's Store
with a lot of groceries,
so that's really kind.
And Abby Cadabby, she's kind to the earth
by watering the plants in her
garden and that's really kind.
And you know what, Drew?
Even Oscar the Grouch can be kind.
He takes really good care
of his pet worm, Slimey.
- Well, in honor of World
Kindness Day, we wanted
to do a little sketch we're
calling Kind Tweets, get it?
Tweet, tweet.
(Big Bird laughs)
(birds chirp)
- You know what, Drew?
I'm really great at tweeting.
(Drew laughs)
Yeah, I tweet all the time.
Tweet tweet, tweet tweet, see?
(audience laughs)
- I would love to follow you on Tweeter.
Well, we're gonna read the
kindest tweets that we found
on the internet to spread
a little happiness today.
Big Bird, are you ready?
- Oh sure, I'm ready, Drew.
- Okay, I'm gonna go first.
@dadof5 tweeted, #hero,
when nine-year-old Reese lost her home
in California's biggest wildfire,
she also lost her baseball
cards, 100 of them.
And she was heartbroken.
And when Kevin Ashford, a
lifelong collector found out,
he knew what he had to do.
He gave her all 25,000 of his own cards.
(audience applauds)
- Wow!
Oh, I love this.
Okay, Big Bird, tweet tweet, you're next.
- Okay, here we go.
This one is from my friend, Ernie.
(audience applauds)
And it says for World Kindness Day,
my old buddy Bert gave me
his favorite argyle socks
to make some new sock puppets.
(audience laughs)
(Big Bird laughs)
Gee, Bert, that was really
kind of you, it says.
(Big Bird laughs)
He's right.
- Okay, that was so kind.
Okay, one more tweet tweet.
@thegoodnewsnetwork
tweets seven-year-old boy
who was bullied opens a huge food pantry,
making his life all about positive energy.
I love this.
Cavanaugh Bell told his mom he wanted
to start a GoFundMe page
to fulfill his mission
of assembling and distributing
care packages filled
with food and toiletries
for his elderly neighbors.
And guess what?
Cavanaugh is here now,
hello.
- Really?
- Hi.
(audience applauds)
- Hello, Cavanaugh.
What an amazingly kind person you are.
What motivates your kindness
and positive attitude?
- Well, I know we're all going
through some hard times right
now and I just wanna make sure
that people know that people feel happy
and that they're loved.
So every day, I think of
how I can make this world
a better place, whether it's
by my care packs or speaking up
and speaking out against bullying.
I wanna show the world that
being positive is cool.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah.
Oh, Cavanaugh, I love what you said there.
It's so so special.
How does it feel to help out
so many of your neighbors?
- It makes me feel so beautiful inside
that I get to have people
have what they need.
And my goal was to help
1,000 people in my community,
but I've helped over 10,000 people,
not in just my community
but all over the country.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
- Wow!
And Cavanaugh, how have
the people responded
to your amazing work?
- Well, they're usually kind of surprised
and sometimes they cry happy tears
because no one has
helped them like I have.
But the most awesome part is
I've been able to inspire kids
to help their community,
like Charlie, my friend.
He's in New Jersey, he's
helping his community.
And Nicholas, my other
friend, he is in Atlanta,
or you could say Georgia,
helping his community.
(audience applauds)
- We are all so impressed
with you, Cavanaugh.
And our friends at Sprouts
and the Sprouts Healthy
Communities Foundation heard
about what you're doing and
would like to help you continue
to spread kindness by giving
you $10,000 in healthy food.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
- Thank you so much.
- Wait, look, Cavanaugh.
Here we go.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
- And Sprouts is such a wonderful market
with such incredible
produce and healthy food
and beautiful quality
companies that they sell.
Oh, I just love them so much.
And I was so thrilled that
they stepped up to the plate
in the way that they
did, all inspired by you.
Thank you, Cavanaugh.
(audience applauds)
Thank you so much.
I was truly star struck by Big Bird.
I mean, who wouldn't be?
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back.
It's time to surprise Alicia
and her sister, Tiffany.
Throughout the hour,
they've been getting a tour
of our building and are
about to enter the studio.
And we have to be quiet
because they have no idea
that we're filming.
- Oh wow!
- Hi.
- Oh!
(sisters laugh)
- Hi!
- Hi.
- Hi, Alicia and Tiffany.
- Oh my God!
Oh my God!
- And guess what, you're on camera too.
- Oh my God!
- It's so nice to meet you.
- Oh my goodness, I
cannot believe we're here.
- I'm so excited to meet both of you.
I just love what you're
doing in the world.
By the way, I'm obsessed
with your logo too.
I'm a nut for graphics.
- [Tiffany] She made it herself.
- Yeah, I made it myself.
Yes, I made the logo myself
and we're obsessed with you,
everything flower and your love
for the environment and everything.
- Our favorite movie is "Ever After".
- Yeah, so we are just so obsessed.
- Well, and sisters is
my entire universe now
because I have two daughters.
So it rules every move I make.
And I loved reading about
how is it true you walked off
a subway and saw this space and
something, a light went off?
- Yes, I was traveling with my sister.
We were coming back home.
And so there was this environmental space
in our neighborhood where weeds
were up to everyone's waist
and there was trash
and people were using
it as a dumping ground.
And so I decided that I wanted
to do something about it
and improve that environmental space
so that the community could use it
for access to transportation, gardening.
And so that started my organization.
- And I mean, I really
wanna learn from you
because I feel like
sometimes we look at things
that we would like to change,
but you actually went ahead,
figured it out, changed it
and then continued the
work on and on and on.
So I mean, I feel like we
have a lot to learn from you.
- Thank you so much.
I mean, the only thing I
could say is everything starts
with one small step.
Sometimes we don't think that
one small action will have
a ripple effect, but doing
one small thing like helping
a neighbor or helping clean
up environmental space
can help improve communities
and help improve our environment,
so just one small thing
at a time, I guess.
- So you did that and then you kept going
and you've done more spaces, right?
- Mm-hm, so I do spaces
throughout New York City
in every borough and I connect
with other community leaders
or people who are like,
"Hey, I have an environmental
project, I need help."
So I give them tools, resources,
help them with everything
that I wish that I had
help with starting out.
- And now that field that
you walked out of that subway
that day and had the light bulb
go off, what is it like now?
- So now, it's a commuter path there.
So it connects all the neighborhoods
with access to the train.
So it's no longer a dirt
path, it's no longer weeds
to the hip and people could
get to garden and go out
and enjoy the space.
Young people get to play there.
So it's a beautiful space now.
- I'm so impressed with you.
I mean, are you guys close?
You look so much alike,
I totally get that you're sisters.
- So we're very close.
We live together.
- We live together.
Yes, and so we're
obsessed with you as well
because we bought our first home
and we renovated the whole
thing ourselves, yeah.
And we picked out paint colors,
- Furniture, everything.
Everything, yeah.
So we do environmental
spaces but we also...
- She's a one-man show.
I'm just her cheerleader, but
on project days I help out.
(sisters laugh)
- Not only do I hope my
daughters have the relationship
that you guys have one day,
but since you love being together,
I'm hoping that you don't
mind if I take you both
to Los Angeles for our premiere show.
- What!
- Yes!
(audience cheers)
(Drew applauds)
- Yes, we would love to go.
- Guess who our first guest is.
It's Jennifer Aniston.
- What!
- I know, I freak out over her so hard.
I love her so much.
- Yes, we love "Friends."
- We love Jennifer Aniston.
- I love "Friends", I
love all of her movies.
I just love her.
I'm so excited because she's someone like
I'm never not gonna
wanna hang on every word.
So I have these suitcases for you
that our producer Alex
Clark thoughtfully chose
in our signature yellow.
- We love yellow.
- You can throw all your stuff
in it and we're flying you
to LA and you're gonna
be there in the audience
in the premiere show as our special guest.
- Oh my goodness.
- Oh my goodness, thank you so much.
- This is amazing!
- Thank you so much.
- I actually wanna take
that kind tennis ball
you just tossed over into our court
and throw it right back onto yours.
We think that you guys are amazing.
And this is gonna be so much fun.
- [Alicia] Yay!
- [Tiffany] Yay!
- All right, LA, here we go!
(sisters cheer)
(audience applauds)
And then you can keep teaching
me how to look at things
that we wanna shift and
change and get on top
of actually doing it and
not just dreaming about it.
- Yeah, I think that's important
and I'm excited to teach you.
I mean, I could learn so much from you,
so that means so much to me.
So yes, I'd be more than happy to.
- All right, sisters, let's do this!
Go sisters, go girls and sisters!
All right, Alicia and Tiffany,
I'm gonna see you guys
this Monday, September 13th
for our season two premiere
on the historic Paramount
lot in wonderful Hollywood.
We're gonna have a great
weekend, see you soon.
Thank you so much.
(sisters cheer)
(Drew cheers)
(audience applauds)
- This is so crazy.
- This is unreal.
- It's so wild.
(light chiming)
(upbeat music)